hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast I'm checking in on you I'm just
checking in on you I am just checking in
to see how your weeks going now see
there's a lot of people out there in the
podcasting world they will do one
podcast they'll [ __ ] talk to you
they'll tell some [ __ ] stories
they'll do some ad reads for old zip
recruit up and they'll say goodbye and
you don't hear for them those
[ __ ] for the rest of the
goddamn week see those those podcasts
they don't care about you the way I do
you see when when you give yourself to
Jesus and you understand that we're all
brothers and sisters I don't look at
y'all I don't look at y'all not just a
bunch of listeners I look at you like my
brothers and sisters praise Jesus praise
Jesus and give me your [ __ ] money
and when it rains out and the waters
come up I ain't letting you in my
[ __ ] arena um I still love that he
didn't [ __ ] let anybody in Joel
Osteen [ __ ] dude was a gangster man
[ __ ] you you ain't get my blue carpet
all wet all right Jesus wants you to get
wet he wants you to float out into the
Gulf of New Mexico can't get that
[ __ ] song out of my head
[ __ ] something man [ __ ] something
in a [ __ ] something so close so close
and yet so far
oh I carried your [ __ ] books to
school that song is so [ __ ] sad it's
a sad song you know what I lived I used
to do you know something I was on I did
an episode you know I got these big
shows coming up f is for family third
season is coming up so I'm starting the
old promotion tour like right now right
now I have 20 minutes between radio
phoners so I figured hey you know what I
mean I'm a guy I'm a guy who does a
podcast right it'd be nice to get 20
minutes this podcast out of the way
that's what I'm doing right now is
you're sitting there going wow this guy
built checked in on me he really cares
about me I'm actually right now trying
to get this out of the way okay if you
want full disclosure all you people out
there all you kids out there in the
internet you know sniffin [ __ ] glue
and [ __ ] trying to make water bottles
stand up after you throw them and I
talked about that on Conan I just don't
understand why everybody finds that so
[ __ ] incredible you know when you
really think of the technology out there
the fact that you can take your own
[ __ ] unmanned helicopter and fly it
over some over somebody's [ __ ] yard
and watch some topless check tan and her
[ __ ] tits right you can do while
watching that in your in your [ __ ]
room okay beating your [ __ ]
millennial dick you know all of us teeth
you would think it's somebody somebody
throw flips of [ __ ] water ball up in
the air if it stands up upright
everybody runs out of the room like they
just saw a [ __ ] witch it's incredible
to me you know that's what's fascinating
that's just fascinating about
entertainment you never you have no idea
what's gonna be a [ __ ] hit and what
isn't right just [ __ ] just sitting there
you're right in the [ __ ] you shoot the
[ __ ] you put it out there you have no
[ __ ] idea that's why when something
is a hit
Hollywood's like oh my
they like vampires [ __ ] make nine
hundred of those until they get sick of
it then they move on to the next thing
like I'm kind of hoping the superhero
[ __ ] is has it finally died down I was
driving down the street the other day by
dou by dou Boop and I saw a billboard by
Bardo Boop and it said the world has
enough superheroes and it just said
venom and I was like oh my god finally
they're gonna make a movie about one of
the bad guys right I can guarantee you
if this movie venom is a [ __ ] hit
next thing you know there's gonna be a
Lex is it Luthor is it Luger is it
looter Lex the ball guide like me you
know whose whole [ __ ] thing is that
like he just can't he can't stand
[ __ ] Superman and his full head of
hair do you know I was talking to
somebody yeah just you know what it is
it's not even a full head of hair
it said he has the audacity to have that
little curlicue right down the front
just mocking you know I bet Lex had a
nice sense of humor at one point before
he got all bitter you know I bet lexical
baby tell his story
I bet Lex had some [ __ ] attributes
that made him special you know but
Superman got that jet-black hair doesn't
he
it's so black he has blue highlights you
know that his uniform just sets it off
which brings out his eyes what color is
his eyes that's when you know you're
like two into superheroes when you know
like what color their eyes are the first
time I opened a comic book and I saw his
steel blue eyes I was just like oh my
god who is this I felt like I just
wanted to swim in the ocean of ant-man's
eyes
what you guys think about stem-cell
research I don't understand why this
country is okay with one [ __ ] one
company you know taking over the food
supply poisoning it and then selling the
company to another company and everybody
just walks away like what they did
didn't just happen like there's not
[ __ ] eight-year-olds walking around
with full [ __ ] beards because of all
the [ __ ] hormones and [ __ ] that
they've put in the goddamn food I don't
understand why this country is okay with
that but stem-cell research is like oh
that's the work of the devil and then
you hear all these [ __ ] stories of
people leaving the country they go out
you know and they get the stem-cell
treatment and they come back to this
country it's like I thought this guy was
a mouth-breathing [ __ ] I mean he just
explained the theory of relativity to me
what the [ __ ] happened
well he got stem-cell research on his
mouth they shot it right into the gaping
hole that he used to have when he would
stare at you mouthing gape when you
would flip a bottle over and it would
land on up right they shot it right into
it was like a mist it was a stem-cell
mist and all of a sudden his eyes lit up
in his mouth closed and now he's a
[ __ ] smart guy now I've heard about
guitar players like their hands from
years of [ __ ] doing the tap on solos
trying to keep up with Eddie Van Halen
you know they [ __ ] get that thing and
they come back and they have the hands
of a 12 year old but they keep the
experience of being on the road it's a
devastating combination you would think
something you know you never you know
it's one of the few times it seems like
you're gonna have your cake and eat it I
mean any sort of movie if I'm writing
that movie script that guy has the hands
of a 16 year old but he loses all of his
[ __ ] experience of being on the road
and all of a sudden he's got to go play
a [ __ ] arena and everybody wants the
legend and he's coming out there with
his young hands I can't remember
he can't remember his sauce I got my
[ __ ] hands fixed but I can't remember
how the song goes
I [ __ ] don't remember this [ __ ] even
though I'm the guy that [ __ ] wrote it
you know that's a Netflix series right
there then you just see what it's like
the Hulk meets Eddie Van Halen and I be
[ __ ] the end of every episode he walks
away with his guitar
you know hitchhiking because he got
booted off the stage again because he
couldn't remember how it went and like
every [ __ ] episode he remembers a
little more of his catalogue but he has
to practice so much that he's [ __ ] up
his hands again and he's losing money
cuz nobody's showing up and now he's not
going to have the money to get the
stem-cell research again so of course
the woman that [ __ ] spun his blood in
the centrifuge becomes his love interest
is anybody writing this down this has to
happen
alright you have my permission to go
into Netflix and you pitched this series
okay you want to see you want to see a
[ __ ] streaming services industry
person's eyes [ __ ] light up you just
walk in go I got an idea for a show it's
like The Incredible Hulk
makes Eddie Van Halen and I guarantee
you you won't even have to get through
the pitch and there's gonna be a [ __ ]
they're gonna slide that check across
the table as they play that there what's
that [ __ ] song that quick little song
they play it's almost like when you
watch Law & Order booboo
they're gonna do that except the Netflix
on it's sort of just a note right isn't
it they just hit one note I know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about
this show it's it's like it's like
Captain America meets c.c. Deville just
hear me out
well my only question will be how does
he get his hair underneath that mask I
mean that's that's what bumps for me
does does he slick it down do we see
some hair
coming out of one of the eye holes I
think that could be funny guys I think
that could be funny though I never laid
a hand on you my much more [ __ ] time
go ahead before the next phone or I got
to do bill where you always funny as a
kid tell us what do you find funny today
how do you come up with your material do
you have writers do you pull from your
real life I just didn't interview these
guys these guys were great but in the
end they go hey Bill Cosby just got
sentenced to 10 to 15 years what do you
think about that well I mean nothing
funny are we gonna end on this anyways
anyways I mean that's that's right up
there with [ __ ] what's-his-face the
tight end from the Patriots you know
just viewing somebody one way and all of
a sudden you just look at him the other
one you're like holy [ __ ] and it just
[ __ ] affects the whole the whole way
you look at their work bill can you can
you separate the comedy from the
drugging and the raping when we return
what got some more bill like you're
familiar with the Hindenburg crash and
we have audio a new audio just surfaced
we found a 78 speed LP from back then of
people on the Hindenburg screaming as
they burned to death
have you heard it yet and what are your
thoughts on this tell the folks what
you're gonna be joking about anyways let
me let me I got several more minutes
before I gotta hit pause and move on to
this next one so anyways this stem-cell
research
you know I got this [ __ ] up shoulder
and I just been you know fixing an old
school I'm thinking maybe when I go to
Eastern Europe you know when I have a
day off on my tour I'm gonna [ __ ]
stop into some local place and like
Transylvania or something to have my
blood spun you know good evening
by one of these [ __ ] guys right is it
true that white people in Eastern Europe
have flat heads like Frankenstein do
they have like bolts coming on the side
I don't know they were behind the [ __ ]
and Iron Curtain the whole time I was
growing up so anyways I was talking to
somebody about this [ __ ] and a buddy guy
all of a sudden likes this is all the
stuff that people are whispering about
right now
hey buddy mine was an Australian he got
his knees done I saw him the other day
he was jumping higher than a [ __ ]
pogo stick alright and all this shit's
getting in my head I'm going like wow
stems this is [ __ ] incredible
doesn't have to do like a baby has to
[ __ ] die or something for them to be
able to do it is that what it is does
the rest of the world not care about
dead babies they just look at him like a
[ __ ] rusted out car you know like a
parts car cuz you're you know you just
taken a little baby liver out of it and
somehow you put I mean I you know bill
it will probably help if you [ __ ]
read up on it
they actually this guy was trying to
tell me that through stem-cell research
they've actually cured male pattern
baldness
but there's so much money in [ __ ]
people like myself throwing Rogaine on
their head I don't do that [ __ ] I did it
one time I leave he felt my heart
speeding up and I don't know if that was
just the panic of me dealing with the
fact that I was going bald or if it's
actually a side effect so allegedly my
heart rate went up and I have you know
if it was I can't remember what the [ __ ]
it was this is back in the 2000s in the
year 2000 in the year 2000 and being
hilarious do you understand how funny
would be if they actually had a cure
for [ __ ] baldness but they're just
making so much money on the snake oil
that they don't let it come out
I was joking last night with some
buddies of mine going do you realize
that that that would be like like
Rogaine and all of those guys are kind
of like big big oil companies and then
the cure for baldness would be like
electric cars or solar you know and I
got to be honest with you I don't think
that's the cure for like [ __ ] the
environment because you know goddamn
well all the raw materials and when you
throw out your old
solar panel so that your [ __ ] Tesla
ends up in the [ __ ] ocean that giant
[ __ ] battery god knows what its gonna
do the environment but I'll tell you
right now that would that would be the
end of us that would be the end of so
many of these [ __ ] terrorist groups
how are they funded they're funded with
oil money you know
so both pollute the environment but only
one of them financed why don't we just
switch over you know if every stadium in
the NFL could go from natural grass most
of them I should say over to astroturf
and then convert to sort of astroturf
with old rubber tires in there if you
could watch the NFL that billion dollar
[ __ ] industry industry changed three
times in your [ __ ] lifetime why is it
that we can't switch over just we should
be having solar power with full heads of
[ __ ] hair you know and then we'd be
family I I think I think I just solved
the entire Middle East problem in about
90 seconds you see that do you see what
happens when you're sitting by yourself
and there's nobody to question your
thoughts or debate you on any of your
points do you see how quickly you are
able to [ __ ] solve problem what do
you mean this [ __ ] he's got a text
message saying he didn't [ __ ] call
anybody yeah II think you missed one of
your phonus I called the 6:45 and the
[ __ ]
7:00 a.m. [ __ ] [ __ ] I got to put
this on speaker here hold on a second
hang on a second people according to my
email I don't have another phone call
until 7:30 a.m. period you got to go
with a period when you do something like
that you know cuz it's polite but it's
Kurt and then they'll be paranoid boy is
he mad at me what is his tone and then
they back off and then they go oh I'm
sorry my mistake even if it was my
mistake they actually take
responsibility and that's how as a
person that stands on a stage and
performs that's how your ego slowly goes
out of control you know and you see
examples of it it would be like seeing
another stand-up comedian talking about
what other stand-up comedians should or
shouldn't be talking about on stage it'd
be like if that happened dance far as I
know the next one I'm calling our backs
in O'Brien be ax and O'Brien in East
Longmeadow Massachusetts and this is
gonna hype my show in Springfield on
October 4th at the mass mutual I can't
wait to do that gig man you gotta
understand like how many gigs I did in
western Massachusetts that did not go
well I told this story I went out to
exit two I got off in Li Massachusetts I
stood on stage in a restaurant I had a
dinner roll thrown at me like [ __ ]
Nolan Ryan [ __ ] threw it my god it
missed me Jesus Christ sounds like a
[ __ ] gunshot when it hit the back
behind the wall behind me I don't know
if it was a stale roll or what but I'll
tell you right now I'm still shaking you
know oh Jesus oh there's it's
message see I told you the period always
works ah [ __ ] I [ __ ] up got my time
zones mixed mixed up I'm sorry see how
that works
let me I'm gonna read this back to you
and said I called the 645 and the 7:00
a.m. period according to my email I
don't have another phone call until 7:30
a.m. period and you keep it like that
no question marks no is that cool was it
me you just fact period fact period send
skip the 731 I'll reschedule it
oh look at this I'm gonna get to knock
out my whole podcast ma don't you though
I didn't [ __ ] up my radio tour somebody
was waiting for old freckles the [ __ ]
calling man talk about his [ __ ] [ __ ]
jokes that he's gonna be telling that
the MassMutual
[ __ ] Center in Springfield
Massachusetts they got the [ __ ] NBA
Hall of Fame you know I love about that
place you get to go in there and take
[ __ ] you in the end they got some
hoops he can shoot a couple of [ __ ]
hoops take a three-pointer you know I've
been to all of them they don't have a
batting cage at the Baseball Hall of
Fame nor should they because that's
that's the purest one that is the
hardest one to get into you know what I
mean you have a better chance of banging
a [ __ ] supermodel than you do of
getting into the [ __ ] you understand it
then getting into the [ __ ] Major
League Baseball Hall of Fame because you
know you go to [ __ ] New York you go
to LA you walk down the street you'll
see one of those supermodels walking
down the street looking like a [ __ ]
giraffe and high heels maybe you say
something maybe it maybe you get throw
him a line maybe you go reverse
psychology
you look at their designer bag and
justice like is that from Jeddah I wish
I knew line of a cheap liner purse is
something something that makes them
question themselves you know not that
I've had this experience before but I
would think that if that is what your
job is every [ __ ] day you're just
looking in the mirror and knowing you're
another day older I know Jesus what am I
talking about that's the business that
I'm in do you know what I mean these
people that come out here and they base
it on their looks or get [ __ ] cuz of
their looks you know everybody's like
they always look at him you know and
they're they love him and then
eventually they date they [ __ ] they
don't like him anymore because they're
good-looking and their beauty reminds
them of the horror that they see every
time they brush their own teeth yeah you
walk into the bathroom you actually had
somebody install a dimmer you have the
light on like 30% you just come walking
in right and just out of memory you know
you're looking down because you just
don't want to catch you don't want to
catch what you see in the mirror you
just look down you grab your toothbrush
you put the toothpaste on and at some
point though you have to look up and you
have to face you it's sometimes you
don't like what you see
that's a tough [ __ ] game you know
it's funny about really good-looking
people like they're the only people who
get called out for aging either either
there were people you went to high
school with look back my high school
reunion Jesus Christ built berlin's say
he's [ __ ] him Papillon Papillon which
his friends for is a butterfly that be
on that meal excusa mom and Mozelle Elia
Papillon a freak oh there's a butterfly
in the refrigerator why is the butterfly
in the refrigerator this is when you
learn French this is the kind of [ __ ]
you learn how to say like [ __ ] you would
never say if you went to France excusa
mama mozilla Elia yeah Pepe on done
enough Regal hey Apple Belle we we're
basically sure I [ __ ] throw the thing
out cuz it's obviously dead kiss go say
sorry I think I'm not gonna [ __ ]
torture you with my goddamn French I
already did that to the wonderful people
of France who had the [ __ ] decency to
say we are not going to accept that
poisoned food from your country unless
you [ __ ] label it and then the
wonderful people of this country were
like dirt no [ __ ] word wrong afraid
water on the floor yes they talk like
the devil on a heavy metal record that's
how I pictured those people we're gonna
oldest truth
put it in your mouth and eat it we will
start making food um I know this is
[ __ ] weird what do you want for me
it's like [ __ ] 7:00 and the more I'm
supposed to be up right now this is
literally like a vampire [ __ ] getting
up at noon to [ __ ] watch The Price is
Right like I should not be 750 vampire
watching the prices might come up people
that's [ __ ] funny it's fine to me in
the morning
higher higher watching the games know
what a [ __ ] Drew Carey retired from
The Price is Right and they hired a
vampire to host it you know they'd have
to start doing the tapings at night good
evening welcome to the price is right
oh my god I'm gonna [ __ ] pitch that
to [ __ ] Hulu all right this is like a
game show meets Bram Stoker's whatever
the [ __ ] I never watched any of those
stupid
[ __ ] movies the last vampire movie I
watched was Brad Pitt and [ __ ] no
that's not true I watched the one where
the little girl was the vampire and her
and her dad moved into the complex that
was a cool one that isn't true I just
told I just basically caught myself in a
lie you know do you know it's been like
a month since I've flown a helicopter
and I just keep seeing these [ __ ]
Magnum PI's ba ba ba ba ba ba wide open
why would that [ __ ] song goes as well
as songs you can't hump except for the
beginning bang a Nandhini and it just
goes off goes off the [ __ ] rail well
bill maybe if you watch the show a
little more you know it's [ __ ] weird
about that show like hey boy let me get
to the point every time I see that
[ __ ] that beautiful md 500 when he's
flying that [ __ ] helicopter I'm just
like I'm like I'm like I'm watching that
[ __ ] show I and I like that think
they went old school with the helicopter
but I feel like they should have given
him a new Ferrari because that's not one
of the classic Ferraris like that
Ferraris not worth a lot of money you
know as far as Ferraris go like you
could you could pick up one of those
[ __ ] Ferraris let me let me know
what's that let's [ __ ] look at the
price of one of those [ __ ] things
right now what do you say there freckles
alright we're looking up Tom Selleck's
Ferrari and we're gonna see how much it
[ __ ] cost Magnum not condoms magnum
p.i do do do do do do but it'll pop it
open too like I keep my mouth closed
magnum p.i Ferrari oh it's the 308 GTS
all right let's look that @f e ar AR AR
i what did I just say
3o
it's GTB and GTS okay let's see the
Friday you [ __ ] wiki pedia [ __ ]
goddamn [ __ ] why does why isn't
my all my [ __ ] defaults go to those
[ __ ] you know what probably cuz you
went to it too many times uh this douche
again wikipedia the bald [ __ ] has
another question for you too late hey
pal good to see you again what how old's
Gavin MacLeod ah [ __ ] 85 alright
Ferrari 308 GTS for sale now I imagine
the price went up cuz magnum p.i is
coming back bowed out I or what I own
Tampa tackler
alright 308 GTS for sale I remember
Barry Katz I trashed him on his own
podcast he owned a half the stand-ups in
the [ __ ] world money and he went out
and bought one of these things yeah
54,000 it's still a lot of money
seventy-nine thousand get the [ __ ] out
of here I want that one joy BAE huh I
don't know I said her name I just want I
look I just want to say her name she's
one of the coolest [ __ ] people I've
met in this business by the way don't
sleep on [ __ ] Joy Behar I did an
episode with crashing with her and she
was [ __ ] hilarious all right uh sixty
four five what about the ones from the
eighties eighty three is seventy nine
thousand nineteen eighty seventy
thousand Jesus you know something
when people buy Ferraris in these
supercars everyone thinks it's a giant
[ __ ] waste of money but you know they
really retain their value there's no way
that [ __ ] car cost that I'm gonna go
out on a limb and say it didn't cost
that amount of money when you first
bought it it actually appreciated in
value after what these bankers did to
this [ __ ] country in 2008 there's
people in houses that are never going to
appreciate value as far as what they
still own it on it people I'm telling
you right now if you want to turn around
you're fine
your [ __ ] situation you sell your
house you buy a Ferrari [ __ ] jts and
you live in that [ __ ]
eventually that car is gonna be worth
more money than you owe for your house
whatever well you sold the [ __ ] thing
but you still owe more than one it was
worth so you know I'm saying there's a
balance there that needs to be dealt
with you don't drive it anywhere you
just [ __ ] do alternate-side the weak
[ __ ] parking and you just sit in it
till one day that [ __ ] car is worth
more than once you own your house plus a
turkey sandwich then you sell it then
you walk down the street you get
yourself a turkey sandwich and you're
like you know what that's delicious and
now I have nothing
what's that country where bankers get
put to death if they do [ __ ] like these
[ __ ] [ __ ] did in this country you
know is it Singapore is it somewhere in
Malaysia
to Thailand is it Laos Vietnam India
China Mongolia Japan Guam Fiji we
honeymooned in Fiji we had a hut it was
so amazing
you look through the floor you could see
the [ __ ] ocean that's one of those
things like if I was a woman and my
husband took me to one of those [ __ ]
huts that sits over the ocean like I
wouldn't be able to sleep comfortably
because I feel like if your husband is
ever gonna [ __ ] kill you it's either
gonna be twenty years into your marriage
or on the honeymoon so you got to get
past that first hiccup and just knowing
that this dude could kill you and then
just drop you right through the [ __ ]
floor you know any other thing ladies if
I can give you any advice like you want
to be in a hotel so if he drops you
through the floor you land in somebody
else's room and at least he's going to
get caught you know
don't go to that [ __ ] hut that's on
stilts above the goddamn ocean don't
take a cruise
don't go scuba diving these are all
[ __ ] stories here I don't know if
they're true it's just people you know
say them and then I repeat them without
ever doing any research there was that
woman she went on a [ __ ] honeymoon
and so much she got eaten by a shark or
[ __ ] like the guy shut off that the
oxygen tank it was on the [ __ ]
honeymoon this is why they should have a
[ __ ] class in high school teaching
people how to get out of a relationship
do you understand this person was in a
[ __ ] relationship with somebody that
they did not want to [ __ ] be with and
all they had to do was just sit down and
say listen we have to talk I'm not happy
I love you but I don't love you in a way
that makes me want to marry you I'm
sorry and that's all you have to say how
long did that take to say that she's
gonna cry be shocked possibly throw
something at you claw you in the face
call the police and said that you
attacked her and then you go to [ __ ]
jail right [ __ ] with you but I'm just
saying it's literally a [ __ ] 50 it's
a 15-second statement I know it's
awkward you don't want to [ __ ] do it
but just memorize it just sit down and
say it so you're not standing there at a
[ __ ] wedding going what the [ __ ] am i
doing and just avoiding confrontation
and standing there going with this ring
Iowa do you flop sweated [ __ ] jackass
agree to take this woman whose [ __ ]
ecstatic because she doesn't know what
you're feeling and you're sitting there
and your heads going don't say it don't
say it don't say you go i doo doo doo
doo and then you're like now how the
[ __ ] do I get out of this now I'm going
to get divorced one day maybe and that's
combination that the [ __ ] divorce
laws is so [ __ ] brutal and all these
strong are out there getting [ __ ]
ridiculous amounts of money for child
support he saw the whole [ __ ] thing
so do you realize rather than just
simply breaking up with the person this
[ __ ] guy goes I know we're gonna get
certified to scuba dive we're gonna go
underneath the ocean I'm gonna shut up
for [ __ ] tank I'm gonna work this
whole [ __ ] story out having never
committed any sort of major crime I
think I'm gonna sit across from the cops
and be able to hold it together and get
away with [ __ ] I'm gonna break the
fifth [ __ ] commandment and for the
rest of my [ __ ] life
I'm never gonna enjoy one day knowing
that I took another life do you know one
time that I know I'm off the rails yeah
you know one time I [ __ ] there was
this rapper from Africa and he was one
of those boys soldiers over there that
[ __ ] gets commandeered at like 9:00
and kills more people than [ __ ] Rambo
by the time he's 11 he was talking when
his album came out he was talking about
all these rappers in America that would
brag about killing somebody and he was
[ __ ] he said one of the coldest
things but like so true well he was just
like basically saying they were full of
[ __ ] he said when you kill somebody you
don't brag about it it haunts you and I
was like oh my god I gotta listen to
this [ __ ] guy's album you know I mean
how do you not [ __ ] listen to that guy
I mean if you listening to this [ __ ] I
know what you're saying right now but
what is the guy's name I don't remember
but I don't think there's a lot of
[ __ ] boy soldiers that turned emcees
out there you know all right how about
I have to do a little bit of advertising
here people I don't have the advertising
yet because I'm so ahead of the [ __ ]
game you know I feel that I did the
apartment I just did the podcasting
equivalent of doing the dishes before
you go to bed
I'm telling about if you suffer from
[ __ ] depression not clinical but just
[ __ ] I don't think it's gonna work
out for me man if that's what your
[ __ ] brain says to you and you want
to start turning it around I'll tell you
something nothing lifts your spirits
like [ __ ] coming downstairs in the
morning and all the dishes are done Oh
walking across your [ __ ] apartment
maybe you're in a [ __ ] studio okay
and the sinks right next to your futon
hey I've been there you know and that
faucet keeps [ __ ] dripping and you
can't get it to shut it off shut up so
you put a towel in there and you just
lay there thinking that you solved the
problem and then eventually the towel
gets too wet and rather than hearing the
sound of the water hitting that [ __ ]
stainless steel it then becomes the
[ __ ] towel and you just hear yep and
then you start thinking maybe I could
get certified to go scuba diving with my
landlord rather than calling a plumber
all right yeah that and making making
the bed make the bed before you go to
work come home but you know something I
don't know what it is you get into a bed
that that's made it's it's more [ __ ]
comfortable the sheets are all [ __ ] up
and everything you just it's just it's
awful you know I mean it's like if you
grab a newspaper off the newspaper stand
and nobody's read it it's just it's just
crisper the words jump out at you but if
you pick one up you know at the bus
station you know pull it off as some
bums [ __ ] face right it just doesn't
seem the same and you know what that's
one to grow on
all right um I'm gonna shut this off and
then I'll [ __ ] splice everything
together and you'll you'll never know
the difference
all right
this is weird you know I guess it's just
pretend like I already have the
advertising all right people we do a
couple advertising reads here hey what's
going on all right it's Pilbara I'm back
I always have to say hey what's going on
when I'm starting I'm trying to get the
[ __ ] copy here for the the goddamn
reads and of course it's not working out
why would it work out why would anything
I totally [ __ ] up with my goddamn
computer the thing was filling up it
told me it was gonna be filled up I
[ __ ] ignored it now it's now it's
completely [ __ ] full and I keep
trying to put him onto these little
[ __ ] lightning sticks whatever the
[ __ ] you call him he's sticking this
audio computer first one worked fine got
all the pictures and video on it second
one I go [ __ ] yourself bill now I got to
play a game now I only have it on one of
these [ __ ] sticks they are called
lightning sticks in my world all right
amigo uh no that's amigo like you know
what's funny back in the day you could
read Lord and Taylor Jordan Marsh now
everybody's got to be so goddamn cool Oh
am i Geo oh my go
Oh me go Oh me go oh me go a
revolutionary toilet seat replacement
for your [ __ ] age are you anal about
cleanliness in the bathroom have you
really ever thought about wiping with
toilet paper like really thought about
it please click for a demonstration in
details yeah I'm gonna skip that washing
washing you in all the right places
oh this is the oh that's the thing here
so it's like a bidet is that what we're
talking about all right let me see okay
they got this smiling guy meet oh me go
oh me go oh my go all right let's listen
to this
amigo a new high-tech toilet seat and it
changes everything it's gonna spray
water up your ass he's no aunty man and
there's a woman [ __ ] doing it yeah
yes she is I can't tell if that sexist
or empowering I mean he didn't know how
to do it she did but she was on her
knees in the bathroom for [ __ ] sakes
how [ __ ] long does it have to be all
right evidently it sprays water up your
ass and that's the way of the future
all right adjust the water temperature
the position in case it's [ __ ] it's
treating you taint like it wants equal
rights what water - what a temperature
position pressure with movement with
yeah I guess there are different size
[ __ ] out there features heated seat
I'll [ __ ] goodness sake are you serious
you see I'm trying to learn how to not
curse in front of my daughter for
goodness sakes JC f and g d MF C alright
a heated seat a night light soft closing
air dry remote control deodorizer is
there not enough global warming that we
gotta turn this thing I mean how much
what is the carbon footprint on this
[ __ ] thing say goodbye to toilet
paper save trees you saving wall have
[ __ ] you saving water maybe I'm save
water and electricity by having a heated
seat and water spraying up your ass as
opposed to a cold seat with toilet paper
you u.s. alone uses 36 million rolls of
toilet paper in one day clean and safe
automatic self-cleaning on-demand silver
ionized sterilized install yourself in
just 20 minutes get $100 off your your
order when you
Oh - oh my oh me go doc oh my go amigo
my Oh me go dot-com / bird that's om IG
o go - oh me go my oh me go calm my oh
me oh go my oh me go calm / bird to get
a hundred dollars off the future seems
weird at first let it be weird
all right maybe I'm behind the times
somehow that's more environmentally
friendly
alright oh look look who it is it's not
us it's hims here's a problem 66% of men
lose their hair by age 35 that's a
sensitive subject with me thing is when
you start to notice hair loss it's too
late
alright well I guess I don't need to pay
attention for the rest of this it's
easier to keep the hair you have then to
replace the hair you've lost all this is
[ __ ] genius we already got the ball
guys dumping [ __ ] on their head let's
get people have full heads of hair to
get paranoid I love this is that
hairline slowly starting to recede start
moving backward any bald spots yet how
will you feel a year from now if it's
business as usual up there well I
thought you just said if it you're
already losing your hair it's too late
some of these kids the way they write
their copy ah boy I'll tell you why do
guys turn to weird solutions or do
nothing well what the feet [ __ ] nah me
yeah this this all of this coffee
[ __ ] all over me when they can they
can turn to medicine and science I
wanted to age naturally a guy what hymns
does is connect with real doctors and
medical grade solutions to treat hair
loss well known generic equivalents to
name-brand prescription prescriptions to
help you keep your hair no snake oil
pills or gas station counter supplements
prescription solutions backed by science
no waiting room no awkward doctor visits
save hours by going to for hems calm
hims calm what about for her
women have alopecia sometimes answer a
few quick questions
doctors will review and can can
prescribe you products are shipped
directly to your door order now my
listeners get a trial month of hymns for
just five dollars right now while
supplies last see websites for full
details this would cost hundreds if you
went to the doctor or a pharmacy well
you could also see the doctor as opposed
to this [ __ ] when you say doctors look
at it how the [ __ ] do I know you know go
to four hymns calm slash bird that's fo
r hims calm slash bur for four hymns
dot-com slash / oh here we go here we go
getting down and dirty on the last one
my bookie everybody that's right who's
playing tonight Thursday Night Football
I don't know who's playing be honest
with you I have no idea
I knew wait I do know Monday Night
Football is Denver in Kansas City
Thursday Night Football Steelers Tampa
Bay was Monday I don't even know all I
know is I'm watching alright you know
ever since I started this podcast people
been asking me for advice ask me what
team to bet on truth is I [ __ ] know
who's gonna win but you know what if you
think you're gonna [ __ ] think you
know you got to check out my bookie
remember who you're betting on is just
as important as who you're betting with
think about it make sense after a while
that's why I always tell people to bet
with my bookie trust me guys they're
your best bet for this season they've
been in business for years have great
reviews online and their mobile site is
easy use my bookie you win they pay I
mean that [ __ ] simple they have in
game live betting the most rewarding
perks in the business and for you
fantasy guys out there oh my God he's on
my fantasy team if I could have one wide
receiver it'd be you you could even bet
over at the over/under on how many
fantasy points a player will score each
game my bookie is slammed with new
betters and wants to give everyone the
best service possible if you're willing
to deposit after 7:00 p.m. Eastern
time they'll give you an additional $25
FreePlay on deposits over $100 join now
and my bookie will match your deposit
dollar-for-dollar use promo code Burpee
you are arts activate the offer visit my
bookie online today
that's my bookie my Bo ok ie and don't
forget to use promo code burr when
creating your account to claim up to
$1,000 in free play and now if you're
willing to hold out until after 7:00
p.m. you can get an extra $25 free play
by using promo code bu our r-25 it's up
to you guys but I'd wait to after dinner
and take that extra money hey you can do
it all you want you ply you win you get
paid I [ __ ] love it
umm how the [ __ ] is adding electricity
to a toilet seat more environment and
and [ __ ] a water fountain up your ass
more environmentally I mean that that
right there that right there was is is
the reason why I don't invent [ __ ]
because on paper man make no [ __ ]
sense all right you guys enjoy the music
there's gonna be another half hour of a
greatest hits Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcast I'm
gonna be at the LA forum tomorrow night
wearing a Larry Bird Jersey no I
wouldn't do that to you
I thought about it but I'm not gonna do
that why don't why not make it an
enjoyable experience I'm gonna be at the
LA forum tomorrow night get your tickets
you only got one more [ __ ] day come
down there see old freckles old freckles
and that big old [ __ ] place I mean
I'm in Denver what dude I called it the
pride of Newark New Jersey Paul Kersey
Paul virzi owner of an absolutely
beautiful Toyota Lexus daddy say it
Lexus by Toyota alright have a great
weekend you cuts go Pat's
[Music]
like a boss okay I am really crying and
I just think it's nice that after all
these years the Emmys finally stepped up
and gave everybody else an award Jesus
my wife was watching that thing last
night what a [ __ ] [ __ ] show
[Laughter]
[Music]
nice a lot feel hey dapper stranger need
a lift in the van with the kids I don't
know man I gotta tell you something
there's no way that it's worse it's for
someone who is into watching award show
an award show to make them watch sports
there's no way that that's a worse
experience than someone who watches
sports having to sit there and watch a
[ __ ] the Emmys you know I didn't have
to sit there I kind of had to had to
because you know I didn't see my wife in
a couple days she was like I wanna hang
out with you and then we had to sit
there and just watch these [ __ ]
things it just uh the actress it's just
so goddamn dramatic Sarah Paulson
[Music]
this is the first Emmy win and
for Serapis I had one of those mouths
wedding drops and now I can't feel my
face so this is a problem it was because
you thought I could that I even dared
because you believed in me I dared to
try I almost [ __ ] threw up whoever
the hell said that because you believed
in me I dared to try it's like you're a
[ __ ] actor it's a killer script you
what you're gonna turn it down that
[ __ ] oj miniseries was unbelievable I
don't believe in me but because you did
I dared I dared to try it was one of the
worst things I've ever heard
you know other than when you call up the
cable company if you let me get sick
when you get into that talking a robot
lady is one notch lower than that I'm
not [ __ ] on the actor you know what
I mean think it got because they're like
that that's why they give the great
performance it's because I'm a [ __ ]
that's why I do stand-up you know what I
mean so everybody finds the little
[ __ ] hole is supposed to crawl into
oh my god this always these just these
are important stories and they need to
be told stories that provoke
conversation necessary conversation but
it also creates privilege when you take
women people of color trans people queer
people and you put them at the center of
the story these subjects instead of the
objects you change the world we found
out just take your shiny thing and leave
just give us the keys ah oh my god
because you believed in me I dared to
try I dared to try the next time my wife
complements me I'm gonna say that to her
because you believed in me I dared to
try these are stories that need to be
told we're storytellers and with us with
out us giving people a voice you know
what else is great you know as the Emmys
I think the Emmys got scared by all this
[ __ ] the Oscars God you know and what
was funny is as many people of color
that won one of the funniest shots all
night long was when you know if you
looked if they just would like do a shot
behind Jimmy Kimmel and you saw the
front row it looked like a great mix of
everybody but when they did the shot
when they'd come back from commercial
and you saw the whole crowd it was like
from the thousandth row up to the third
row it was all white it was like it
looked like a foreigner concert from the
back row all the way like the third row
but if they did it the way they shot it
the front end loaded like the 15 black
people that were there they just had
them all right in front there you go
take the whole thing some Asian people
and all that but all the way to the back
I was joking with Nia like you if you
live in New York City every once in a
while you go into one of those bodegas
that's either dealing drugs are just
going out of business little corner
stores called bodegas say it with me
Oh Degas and it looks like it's [ __ ]
stocked with food and you grab that one
can of food and you look at this like
behind that can this is just completely
empty so I did get some laughs while
watching it Jesus Christ the weight of
every [ __ ] thing that they say it's
just unbelievable
when that [ __ ] guy just said say like
I hope you realize the presence of
greatness that we are at you know just
like Jesus Christ if you [ __ ] get
pretending to be a fireman relax
[Music]
we've arrived at a difficult moment of
course it was so brave it was such a
brave performance you know I mean
there's this [ __ ] people up day they
had a builded skyscrapers and [ __ ] all
those guys who go up and they change you
ever see those things
Mike Mike palms literally sweat watching
these people they climb all the way up
those towers to change the [ __ ] light
the little lightbulb at the top of the
tower at the top of the [ __ ] building
so no plane can see it at night and they
got that part where they unhook the
safety thing free climbing is more
dangerous of course but OSHA rules do
allow for it
Jesus Christ is putting on 20 pounds and
wearing a wig is brave what the [ __ ] is
that huh you can't die acting kanya well
I guess you can there's ways to die as
an actor right the fake gun on set turns
out it's got you know you put it up to
your head there's that they [ __ ]
bring a helicopter people have died on
set so no disrespect to them 29 minutes
a yammerin built jesus [ __ ] christ
you know some days the podcast is hard
other days it's easy but I just want to
say to everybody who listens because you
dare to download I dare to try
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
the Monday morning podcast for Monday
September 27th 2010 and and it is still
Monday for all you [ __ ] [ __ ]
giving me [ __ ] saying I haven't you
haven't posted a podcast what the [ __ ]
going on it's still Monday it's still
Monday morning we're at where I live
it's not my fault I live I live at the
end of the street you know I live at the
end of the [ __ ] street when it comes
to the world you realize that [ __ ]
other than Hawaii you know and maybe
Amelia Earhart's [ __ ] great-great
grandson a grandson at this point right
big grandson she crashed made it to an
island [ __ ] some goddamn Aborigine right
bangs a tune ends up having a [ __ ]
baby some [ __ ] group of people that
we haven't figured out that they lived
there yet so we could exploit them
destroy their goddamn culture and put up
a [ __ ] Best Buy you know maybe maybe
those are the only people who don't
[ __ ] at me it is 2:00 Monday morning
podcast it's 943 Monday [ __ ] morning
okay so is the Monday morning podcast
all right all right there epic fail guy
who sent me the email oh you want to see
an epic fail why don't you look up when
you're shaving next time buddy all right
I'm in a [ __ ] mood I am in a mood
today because my computer sucks server
not found what does that even mean what
the how am i offline Jesus now you guys
gonna see what what kind of skills I
really [ __ ] have considering I'm not
even online right now they just took
away my little security blanket
hey somebody sent me an email talking
about irony
you know the segue you know that little
two-wheeled thing will you lean forward
and it goes for and then you lean back
and then it stops or something like that
evidently it's it's you know it's you
know one of those devices they made
because I think that they felt like
people weren't fat enough and if there's
any way if we could just eliminate all
walking anyways this this
whay owner died after falling off a
river cliff riding a Segway I know it's
it's not a nice thing to do to laugh at
someone who dies I know that they have
family so I'm um you know well what the
[ __ ] and just a whole name of its Segway
you know the Segway brought him from
this life into the afterlife that was
the Segway Jesus Christ I'm what was he
thinking on that fall I should have
walked
oh and you know he was wearing those
[ __ ] shoes with the tassels you know
those ones that rich people where are
those [ __ ] loafers you know they
always wear the loafers without the
socks and they got their khaki shorts
and some sort of yachting polo shirt I
bet he always dressed like that he's
probably on his cell phone maybe was
texting well he had another one up
against his chubby rich cheek from all
those [ __ ] hams he used to eat at
that long dining room table take off my
segue go for the spin around the [ __ ]
river that we bought and you know would
be [ __ ] hilarious as if he when he
went over the cliff I bet he had a death
grip you ever hear of what a death grip
is well I'm gonna tell you even without
the internet sometimes when when you're
when you're in it in a situation where
you're gonna die and I think it involves
falling your body has what's known as a
death grip and it's you just hang on so
[ __ ] tight like I saw this one time
it was basically there was those two
guys flying in a plane two guys flying
into a plane walk into a bar
the bartender says hey you you can't
[ __ ] Park that in here willed to do
to guys are flying this [ __ ] plane
right and the rear door Act I believe
they say was was making some noise and
they thought it might be a little bit of
jar so the copilot goes I'm gonna go I'm
gonna get up and I'm gonna secure
the door in the aft section of the
airplane so the other guy says yeah I'm
gonna sit up here with my [ __ ]
seatbelt on you go over there and learn
about air pressure so this [ __ ] dude
goes back any in in his effort to secure
the door aft of the airplane I'm in the
aft section of the airplane we need all
you to take your seat please we haven't
come to a full stop at the jet way yet
shut up you [ __ ] um he goes back there
and I don't know he went to try to shut
it and the [ __ ] door pops open this
is one of these small Cessna planes you
know when you open the door like the
stairs are on the inside of the door and
you plop it down and then you come down
if some [ __ ] puts a lay around your
neck one of those planes then you go
surfing and get [ __ ] hit by a Tiki or
whatever one of those planes so the door
pops open and this guy somehow as he
goes to fall out he's falling out
backwards or maybe he grabbed the
railing or whatever I know is this
[ __ ] dude went out the plane so the
pilots up front going holy [ __ ] my
friend just died so now he's got to land
the plane which isn't a problem but that
the problem is is that the door was was
ajar the door aft the aft section of the
airplane is now a jar and he's wondering
is it gonna drag long story short he
[ __ ] lands the plane and when he gets
out of the plane or walks to the back of
the plane he sees the copilot laying
like head at the bottom of the stairs
feet like still in the plane and his
hands gripping the [ __ ] skinny little
banisters so he tries to get this guy to
let go and the guy is in like this
catatonic state and the the [ __ ]
announcer the host of the show was
saying it took the [ __ ] Fire
Department 20 minutes to pry this guy's
fingers off of the goddamn banister
things because he had what's known as a
death grip
I mean do you realize just mentally
where you go in that moment where your
brain overrides everything other than
keeping your heart beating in your
respiratory system going the only thing
your brain is saying is don't [ __ ]
let go grab onto that [ __ ] it's just
it's not even saying hang on I think
it's just white noise it says hang on
you have that thought and then it's
going nonstop until you gradually come
out of it and you look at and they
upside down firefighters face that
stupid mustache and the smell of chili
because he cooks in the firehouse
telling you it's okay to let go now so
with that long [ __ ] story
I bet this fat son of a [ __ ] had a
death grip on his Segway went right to
the bottom of the river ah Jesus Christ
you know what kills me is that thing was
completely [ __ ] useless completely
useless I don't understand what what
purpose it served and that guy made he
became a billionaire the problem was is
that they were 10 grand cuz you know
goddamn well if those [ __ ] things
were 500 bucks everyone would have won
like a [ __ ] iPod we would just be
going down the street looking like the
beginning one of those Star Wars movies
you know where they have all the what is
that what is that computer technology
that they always use that ruins every
[ __ ] movie that's what it looked like
it looked like that computer technology
that I don't know the name of and I
can't even tell you what it is because
my [ __ ] internet isn't working
so anyways the body of 62 year old James
helsdon
Hazleton and a Segway personnel
transporter were found in the river
wharf I know what the [ __ ] he said and
he was pronounced dead at the scene
I'm sure he was with his [ __ ] legs
sticking up out of that River mud
he my I bet he hit terminal velocity
went in there like a [ __ ] meteor
there's probably some conspiracy there
is trying to say it was actually a
flying saucer and they're just covering
it up and they actually killed this guy
police said a witness had reported
seeing a man fall Sunday over a 30-foot
drop into the river near Boston Spa 140
miles north of London the incident is
not the Blee is not believed to be
suspicious police said is it believed to
be ridiculous yeah I would have loved to
been there listen to those cops making
those [ __ ] jokes just the awkward
silence and then somebody [ __ ] kills
it with a joke there had to be something
that I can't think of right now
you guys want to write a joke for that
I'll read them next week there's you
that sure that's your homework
assignment what did the [ __ ] London
police say the first guy who made the
joke about the Segway guy who went
[ __ ] 200 something miles an hour into
the bottom of a river bed with his own
[ __ ] invention has that ever happened
before
has the weight of any great inventors
invention ever just sent them I guess a
plane maybe I mean that's some Frank and
just Frankenstein [ __ ] right
I made you really isn't good segue is
not alive does anybody ever ridden a
Segway now that I'm [ __ ] all over
see the battery-powered Segway which is
stabilized by by gyroscopes was invented
by Dean Kaman who founded the company in
1999 wait a minute oh it's just a Segway
owner I thought this was the guy who
[ __ ] invented it my fault oh he's
just a wealthy businessman Jesus Christ
isn't that classic me the [ __ ] have
half the goddamn information oh so it's
not the guy who invented the [ __ ]
thing it's just some rich bastard who
had one he didn't want to walk anymore
you know it actually looks like a
hot-shit you know like you drank some
scotch and can tell a story Jesus Christ
now I'm starting to feel bad
who the [ __ ] is Dean Kaman founded the
company in 1999 the unique transporter
relies on electricity to recharge its
batteries and travels up speeds up to
twelve and a half miles an hour
I guess it's far more protective of the
environment than other scooters and
automobiles the company says well Jesus
Christ that's a big [ __ ] red flag
according to us our products the best
claiming it's 11 times more efficient
than the average American car yeah in
[ __ ] 30 times slower you know what
[ __ ] Dean came in all right if you
learned anything from this week's
podcast [ __ ] Dean Kaman all right so
anyways I just got back from Nashville
Tennessee
Nashville [ __ ] Tennessee and I had a
great goddamn time out there I saw way
more people out of my shows than the
last time so let it go has been a great
thing for me so I want to thank
everybody who came out cuz I have a
tough time when I go down south for all
you guys who ever you know send me
emails going you know you know come to
Mississippi come to North Carroll aqui
come on Bill you know you like college
football come on to South Carolina
check out the I'm Gamecocks and do a
[ __ ] show the problem is is I don't
[ __ ] talk like this so none of the
other [ __ ] show up you guys don't
[ __ ] show up because I'm not standing
on stage with a camouflage button-down
shirt you know and a pair of mutters
whatever the [ __ ] you call them rubber
boots you wear when you go out stomping
around in the [ __ ] mud I'm actually
jealous of your ability to hunt got a
goddamn animal
fix it know where to shoot it right I
would do the south a few [ __ ]
would show up I have a great idea for a
tour I have a great idea for a tour all
right playing different venues and it
involves me going to some of my favorite
teams in the SEC for those of you who
only kind of like NFL football feel like
you could become a bigger football fan
I'm telling you don't sleep on college
football it's absolute insanity
like at this point just about every
stadium holds at least eighty to a
hundred thousand people and it's [ __ ]
packed every goddamn one I would go to I
would go see any team in the SEC except
for that Mississippi one where it's
80,000 people with cowbells I have no
desire to go into that [ __ ]
environment I think I really I'm really
not into the noisemakers that's why I
don't work New Year's Eve anymore you
know I like all the women coming out
there and the with their drunk
boyfriends and they got that Great
Gatsby JP Morgan [ __ ] hat on except
it's plastic why would you want to I
mean is there anything more annoying
than those little horns that people blow
on New Year's remember Jim Carrey in
Dumb and Dumber and he goes you want to
hear the most annoying voice ever and
that's what he sounded like and that's
what it was so [ __ ] funny to me cuz
when he did that aside from the
hilarious look on his face it
immediately reminded me of standing on
stage after I've done my set and I'm
counting down Billy mind doing the
countdown you mind doing you me you mind
starting you're near that way standing
on stage going Ted nine you know what I
would I would mind doing this I resent
this entire [ __ ] thing and the worst
was whenever you do the when you play a
shitty club that doesn't know what the
[ __ ] they're doing the classic move that
they make is they hand out the
noisemakers before the show which you
know I don't even need to get into the
details of why that's so [ __ ]
horrific but I remember a long time ago
I was working Nick's comedy stop in
Boston and WBZ the local [ __ ] station
there wanted to shoot something for New
Year's Eve and we were shooting it in
November so they handed out all the
noisemakers before any of us went up on
stage and I remember there was this
comedian Chris Zito
and I had no idea you know I was so new
I had no idea that that was gonna be a
problem and I just remembered when I saw
the look on this seasoned headliner
Chris Zito's face the look of panic on
his face and he came walking into the
club and the second he heard of this
look I had never seen on his face
because he's always you know relaxed
dude and he's gonna what why did he have
noisemakers who handed out the
noisemakers he went right up to the
person who ran the [ __ ] and kudos to him
got them to walk around the entire room
and collect all the [ __ ] noisemakers
before we did the show which now I
realized the brilliance of that move
because we were gonna go on television
and we would have bombed with in the
background during our entire [ __ ]
sets that was a long way to go
but anyways so what I'm saying is I
appreciate everybody coming down hang on
one second did I just [ __ ] blow this
whole thing alright so evidently I
didn't [ __ ] it up I thought I'm glad I
didn't but I just saw this this plug was
sticking way up now how the [ __ ] can I
be sticking out that far and it doesn't
matter what is the purpose of having it
in there see that look at me blaming
technology rather than myself anyway so
that was a New Year's story shut up I'm
gonna pick up the ball and run with it
so what I was talking about is college
football if you want to get into college
football tone you watch the SCC for my
money
that's where it's at I [ __ ] I love
like every goddamn team in there except
for like Vanderbilt like teams that just
suck every year but uh when I was
tempted when I was in Nashville to drive
the two and a half hours or whatever
just to go see the first like I don't
know halfway through the third quarter
of the Tennessee game cuz I've always
wanted to go to a game out there you
know that Purina Cat Chow [ __ ] lookin
endzone and a hundred thousand people
going absolutely insane but I don't know
I just might show was it seven then I
was gonna have to leave and I would have
been [ __ ] hammered I know I woulda
drank and I would have been driving
across the 40 40 [ __ ] West going back
to [ __ ] Nashville hmm so anyways
let's talk a little NFL football shall
we
another awesome week of football and
this week I actually gambled a little
bit I got a little running thing going
with uh another buddy my another comic
buddy of mine we're around well
basically we're picking three games each
week and you got a bet against the
spread and I went what did I go I think
I went well I went one in two but if I
tease them I would have won I think I
would have this is what I had the team i
won
I had the bills getting 14 and a half
which I almost [ __ ] lost but uh I
just did I hate the Patriots defense is
[ __ ] horrific you know we let up a
ton of yards against the Bengals we let
up like I can't remember that Jill was a
Jets game was it thirty was it over
thirty was at 38 I can't [ __ ]
remember we got our asses kicked at
[ __ ] defense looked horrible in that
game and our deep we just let up 30
points to the bills so sad to say
Patriot fans myself included I I see us
going like if this trend continues at
best I think maybe we're a 9 and 17 and
I was joking with my buddy watching the
Patriots you know we look like we look
like a [ __ ] like a 2001 Corvette
that's the only way to describe it you
know what I mean where it can still
[ __ ] go zero to 60 really fast but it
has a little that good [ __ ] sound you
know still a Corvette but you know it's
been beat on a little bit I don't know I
don't know how to explain it it's just
like we seem to have a lot of the tools
but like we have no [ __ ] pass-rush
great against the run book and I don't
know that one play where I mean who the
first of all who the [ __ ] is the bills
quarterback that's what really scared me
you know I mean some people just have a
look in their face they look like a
quarterback and then other other people
look like they work at Home Depot and
whatever the [ __ ] that guy's name was
Fitzgerald I don't know what his god
guys goddamn name I was watching in a
sports bar watch the first half in in
Nashville and they had the sound down
because everyone was watching obviously
a tightness game because I was in
Tennessee and I just kept looking at
that guy's face and his red [ __ ]
beard and I was just like is that Eric
Hipple who the [ __ ] is that and he was
just he was just going right down the
goddamn field against us so uh I don't
know this is this weird part of the year
where a few if you gamble because you're
trying to figure out you know what your
team is which is really if you had any
brains you wouldn't gamble for like the
first six weeks of a season until you
got some sort of consistency right
because as much as I talk [ __ ] about the
Jets it's like they kick the [ __ ] out of
the Patriots you start taking well wait
a minute maybe all this talking is for
real but then it's like you you kicked
the [ __ ] out of a team that that gave up
30 points to the bills you know and then
you go down to the Dolphins you play the
Dolphins and the Dolphins have no
[ __ ] offense to speak of and it you
basically couldn't put him away until
the final [ __ ] 20 seconds if that guy
had a [ __ ] goddamn arm that would
have been it you know well no that's
what you can't say that because I needed
a two-point conversion but I don't know
so okay let me finish with the bets I
had then I had to [ __ ] Lions I'm
getting 13 and a half I lost that one
and then I had the Saints given three
and a half I went against my my theory
about divisional rivalries and I was
gonna bet the Dolphins but I just didn't
like them given three to the Jets just
because the Jets have a great great
defense and I didn't like the fact that
the Dolphins had no offense so I stayed
away from that one and if I had to you
know what it was I think I was leaning
towards taking the Jets with the points
and I just couldn't [ __ ] get myself
to then every rooting for the Jets and I
just couldn't get myself to do it so
having said all that the team that I
think right now looks the best to me is
the Pittsburgh Steelers they have three
and Oh with the third stink third string
quarterback and their defense looks
[ __ ] unbelievable in that big they
say that's what wins championships
all right and I got a couple of emails
some Jets fans going you're still gonna
keep hating on the Jets you know typical
jet fans are all excited because they're
two and one three games into the season
right then old fat boy wrote on that bus
they're going to the Superbowl he says I
know you hate the Jets but are you gonna
let that cloud your objectivity and pick
the Jets to lose for the next 13 weeks
no I'm not and that's actually a fair
question because I hate New York teams
to such a level that it will cloud my
objectivity but I wouldn't I wouldn't
get too excited there buddy boy
you guys have I mean the only team I
think that you really played that had a
serious like playoff defense was the
Ravens and they held you to like nine
points so you know I'm sure you're
excited about beating the Patriots but
be honest with yourself true football
fans the fact that the team that you
kicked the [ __ ] out of just let up 30
points to the goddamn jet I'm bills I
mean do you think Jets do you guys think
that you're gonna do that I'm actually
going to that game by the way the Bills
Jets game I am going to that game
because I'm doing a theater in Buffalo
the Saturday night right before the game
and I'm gonna hang out I'm gonna go
there and with all my heart I'm gonna
root against the Jets even though I know
the bills are gonna [ __ ] lose yeah so
anyways is that all boring to people who
aren't into [ __ ] sports so I still I
would say at this point I would say the
two top contenders I would say the
Steelers too early to say the Chiefs
whether they're for real or not and just
because the Colts seemed to win 13 games
every year but they always blow it in
the [ __ ] playoffs but the best thing
that Jets have going for I seriously
think is the fact that Sanchez hasn't
thrown an interception yet and yes I
hope that jinx is him into throwing five
next week but if he's going to play like
that
you know I don't know I just didn't
you're not a [ __ ] Super Bowl team
[ __ ] the Jets alright let's get to some
YouTube videos no you know what I got it
I got to tell you something that's been
[ __ ] bugging the [ __ ] out of me
you ever have a friend you just [ __ ]
outgrow them you know what I mean I
don't want to get into this [ __ ] you
just [ __ ] yeah just it's like you
know you're chugging along you're doing
your [ __ ] your life's going good
their life isn't going good and then
eventually what that ends up happening
is all of a sudden they just start
making little snide remarks about your
life you know and then he got to sit
there and go wow that was [ __ ] weird
and then I do it I was just [ __ ]
around I'm sorry man I'm [ __ ] they
always end up apologizing no I'm just
going through some [ __ ] bla bla bla bla
bla and then it just kind of becomes
more and more and more I you know I got
this [ __ ] buddy of mine and it's just
like you know he's one of these [ __ ]
guys his life is all [ __ ] up
just think of every dumb thing that you
could do every dumb thing that you could
do to [ __ ] up your life you know smoking
weed gambling you know being high at
work flunking drug tests losing jobs
getting drunk falling down [ __ ] up
your face that type of [ __ ] that type of
[ __ ] right one of those [ __ ] guys
calls you up with a crisis every six
[ __ ] weeks dude you never believe
with Abood and it's never their fault
one of those [ __ ] guys where it's
just like all right you know you choose
to live your life that way that's how
you live your life but then they [ __ ]
come and make snide remarks at you and
then you want to come back and just
[ __ ] unload on him you know and be
like dude you're [ __ ] a drug test
working at a goddamn fruit stand you
[ __ ] loser you know why don't you
come home and blow some more [ __ ]
weed smoke into your family's face as
you give them you know three dollars for
the [ __ ] week you know that's what
you want to say but you don't you wait
to your podcast yeah man it's just like
ah that's one of those that's one of
those things you guys hey you guys have
any stories like that cuz I don't really
want to talk anymore about this but I
know you do come on some of you guys out
there you're doing well right maybe
somebody you're friends with when you're
both struggling with who isn't doing
well yet alright but they're so busy
focusing on on what you're doing that
you know they they start giving you this
roundabout [ __ ]
oh my god let's [ __ ] do saw my
special right and leaves me this [ __ ]
up message right and then just hangs up
and I'll call them back for like you
know ten days or whatever week or so I
call it dude up I'm like listen to what
the [ __ ] with that message you know
it's like if you're not happy with your
own life fix your life the [ __ ] you
taking it out on me for you know and
then he in and he texts me back some
[ __ ] about a dude I was just joking
don't be so insecure you know and it's
just really is that what the [ __ ] and
then I go to call him and his phone is
off [ __ ] idiot I mean security the
guy's got a [ __ ] smoke weed all the
goddamn time turn your life into a movie
cuz you can't [ __ ] deal looking at
the goddamn ceiling I you [ __ ] [ __ ]
anyways let's plow ahead here plowing
ahead plowing ahead if you got any
[ __ ] stories like that this is just
getting negative um let me oh do I want
to [ __ ] unload on this guy I want to
[ __ ] unload on this guy I really do
and I'm gonna say I just know I'm gonna
say [ __ ] and then that's just gonna be
the end of it and that's why I'm not
that's why I'm just choosing my world's
words very carefully still saying things
really kunti but I'm not worried about
him here in this cuz he's too [ __ ]
high till even he doesn't know how to
use a computer you know so I basically
could go off and whatever send me your
stories so cathartic ly I can [ __ ] I
in a cathartic way if I'm using that
word correctly I can go off on your
friends rather than my own alright let's
get into some advice the ass bill
section of the week bill I'd appreciate
it if you could give my friends some
advice concerning a girl
my friend is in college and works
part-time at a restaurant is a waiter
within the past few weeks they hired a
girl to host and bus tables on some of
the days he works I think I'm gonna say
literally this girl was hosting and
bussing tables I was just like that's
nasty I told you guys that story right
when I was working for that restaurant
that was going out of business and at
one point I was the grill shift I know
how I told this story but I actually
worked on a mesquite grill with one of
those Top Chef hats on glassed-in like I
knew what the [ __ ] I was doing and I
also bus tables and wash the dishes you
know in this like I'd cooked the meal
and as I was cooking it I would be
watching other people trying to see if
they were done eating and when they were
I would duck down behind the grill take
off the hat in my apron and underneath
it I had that half a tuxedo that you
wear in a restaurant that tries to look
like it's fancy and I would come out
there my face red from working on the
grill from being so goddamn hot in there
I'd bust the table and then I would go
back throw out the food scrape off the
plates and load up and load and it
[ __ ] put it in the dishwasher not
wash my hands because I didn't have time
because I had to run back to make sure
the medium-rare burger didn't become
medium that's what I thought you were
suggesting there so keep an eye on the
employees people make sure there's no
double agents at the [ __ ] restaurants
you go to or you do not want to eat
there little tip all right all right
here we go
plowing ahead what the hell were we they
develop they quickly developed a
relationship where he would hang out in
her dorm between classes for hours at a
time doing what college kids do I guess
he really thought that she was the one I
tried to tell him to slow down a bit
because nothing good comes from
obsessing in that early pre relationship
period anyways a week into it she tells
him that she's really not looking for a
relationship because she doesn't want to
get tied in with the guy and get
distracted from school they pretty much
agree to be friends with benefits in
parentheses he says I hate that term
yeah they're gonna be [ __ ] buddies
sounds reasonable to me then I guess he
overheard something during work or he
had called her and this other guy
answered or something answer the phone
anyway he finds out that she's already
going out with some other
dude like a full-on relationship so now
my friend has to work with this [ __ ] and
try to go on like nothing happened
happened you know it's great why my
voice always cracks because I [ __ ]
scream I act the night before actually
the two nights before so he has to go
around and act like nothing happened
what should he say to her I feel bad for
him since he would talk on and on about
her about this girl every day I
appreciate the insight bill if you read
this all right
all right what should he say to her
nothing
he shouldn't say anything she's a young
girl who doesn't know how to get out of
a relationship yet or maybe she's afraid
to be alone I don't know what but what
he should do is he should stop
attempting to [ __ ] his best move is
just to be cool it's gonna be hard
because he likes urges Peck hey what's
going on and and kind of leave it at
that and if she comes up like how come
you're not talking to me no there's
something weird what's going on and just
be like look I'm not trying to be a jerk
but I kind of got wind that you're that
you have a boyfriend
and so you know I don't mess with girls
who have boyfriends that's all I'm not
judging you or anything but yeah so you
know I actually kind of liked you and
when I found out you had I guess that's
the first thing you should do there you
go putting the cart before the horse he
should find out but I really wouldn't
find out from her find out from someone
who kind of knows and just big she has a
boyfriend right and then and then when
you've clarified that she has a
boyfriend then just keep the
conversation short eh how you doing blah
blah blah and eventually when you don't
try to when he your friend doesn't try
to [ __ ] her again or hook up or whatever
she's gonna be like you know what's
going on just things seem like what's
going on with you hey you hey you know
we do that [ __ ] trying to feel yes it's
a matter everything all right between
Mike
things are so cool cuz I just kind of
noticed you know just kind of let me
said hello to me but used to stop and
you know maybe give me a compliment
they're like well the head of that
[ __ ] right and just be like yeah you
know I just kind of heard through the
grapevine that you have a boyfriend a
serious full-on relationship boyfriend
so kind of threw me for a loop because
you never brought it up oh yeah that um
okay all right I should have said
something and right there you know she's
just trying to worm her way out of it
with the long pauses between what she's
saying yeah that [ __ ] and just I
just don't say anything and just look at
her and she stammers her way through it
if she does she might be one of these
people who she's probably gonna just
turn around and [ __ ] walk away
because she doesn't like confrontations
she could deal with confrontation she'd
get out of that [ __ ] relationship be
like look I'm not happy I'm not happy
okay I yeah so get your books in your
letterman jacket and [ __ ] beat it you
know whatever the hell you got to say
yes I did I give any advice or did I
just imitate this girl that I never met
that's what I would do I would confirm
from someone who knows her really well
that she has a boyfriend and when she
and and just be nice to her hey what's
going on you don't wanna create any
[ __ ] [ __ ] at work cuz you need the
job you don't to lose your any money or
whatever look at the end of the day you
[ __ ] banged her alright so that's a
plus you know that's not the kind of
girl you want to marry someone to be in
a full-on [ __ ] relationship and would
would uh try to set up where you you're
you're [ __ ] somebody else on the side
that's not the mother of your kids you
know I mean grant you only saving her
she's young so she has some growing up
to do but yeah you don't to be involved
in that
cuz next thing you know you're the
in the full-on relationship with her and
she's banging some other way to run the
side when she doesn't have to break up
with you
so I would stay away from that girl and
that's it
then I would also stop [ __ ] people
where I work that's another thing you
don't [ __ ] where you eat where you eat
it's something you do when you're young
you know you just you just [ __ ] your
vicinity and you're Finiti but uh yeah I
would try to avoid doing that so that's
that's basically my advice do you want
me to say it again I just keep saying
the same thing over and over again in
different order that's that's how I
would handle that situation and and with
that I think I'm pretty much out of
information that people have given to me
this week let me do the math here I've
done
36 minutes I owe you another 14 the [ __ ]
am I gonna talk about if I could get on
the goddamn internet I try to [ __ ]
pick some teams next week who do you
guys like tonight Green Bay in the Bears
this is one of these classic early
season matchups are we gonna get to see
who's for real you know which Bears team
is going to show up the one that
technically lost to the Lions in the
first [ __ ] week or the one that
manhandled the Cowboys last week I don't
know I like Mike Martz as a [ __ ]
offensive coordinator if I was a gamblin
man cuz I just do [ __ ] you know
we're basically it's like a hundred
bucks for the year whoever has the best
[ __ ] record I know it's a [ __ ] bet
go [ __ ] yourselves but if I had the
gamble tonight this might be uh if I
would take the home team I would take
the [ __ ] home team on this one well
how the [ __ ] can you say that bill
without seeing that goddamn point spread
that's a great point that is a great
[ __ ] point come on get me on line
bail is [ __ ] money for this [ __ ]
whatever you guys wanted some youtube
videos for the week I got some great
ones I have some great ones here we go
african-american man hoses off a white
woman who called him and it's basically
the n-word all right you have to watch
this video it's [ __ ] phenomenal and
like I always say if you want to rather
than search all of these yourself just
go to the mm podcast.com th e mm podcast
calm the MM podcast calm the official
fan page for the Monday morning podcast
we'll have all the YouTube videos right
in a [ __ ] row and you can just you
can just blow right through them
alright so look up african-american man
hoses off a white woman who called them
the n-word and it's just awesome she's
in one of those motorized you know those
motorized carts that people who can walk
but you know don't feel like it drive I
don't understand them it's different
than a wheelchair wheelchair for the
most part means you can't walk but those
motorized carts mean I don't know I
think you can't walk for long yeah you
can't walk for long distances and so
these are sort of driving and you have
an inability to stand up on a Segway and
you're worried that you're gonna drive
off a cliff and go into a [ __ ] River
so anyways this guy's washing his
[ __ ] 85 Caprice Classic I believe and
this woman just [ __ ] is on the other
side of the street yelling at him and he
just starts [ __ ] you know what I love
it's not that he just sort of like you
know back and forth hoses are off like
he's spraying a garden he full-on
blaster in the face and just holds it
there and it's really great because it's
the whole like when black people used to
you know we had to march for civil
rights and the [ __ ] evil white people
would be holding the hose in their face
it's come full circle now here we are 40
[ __ ] years later 50 years almost and
now the black dude is holding it in the
white person's face but it's just a
garden hose so it's hilarious
he's just spraying her just not moving
it going say it again say it again [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] awesome uh and when she
drives away in the end and is still
giving him [ __ ] and she's soaking wet
I mean it was just one of the [ __ ]
great laughs I've had and that's just
one of the I just it was awesome I just
[ __ ] die and laugh and watching it and
alright here's a next one this one is
actually really I can't believe this guy
didn't get hurt really bad airbag test
in Russia this guy has to go at least 9
feet in the [ __ ] air and lands like a
goddamn rag doll and his friends are
just laughing at him I mean just the
concussive force alone what that would
do to your eardrums is is beyond me and
speaking of that a reoccurring theme on
this podcast I've brought it up a few
times because I've done permanent damage
to my ears from seeing bands live music
and playing drums I'm telling you
because I was out in Nashville my buddy
out there took me out to some clubs and
I always have the earplugs and I was
actually talking to this guy who was
about my age and from what his friends
was saying you know got a lot of ass
back in the day alright and he was he
saw that he had on earplugs he goes what
he goes do you wear those all the time I
go yeah I try to he goes yeah cuz
recently I went to the doctor and the
guy said hey will you ever in the
military and he said no and he asked did
you work in a machine shop basically
asking all those [ __ ] questions and
the guy just said no and I'm telling you
it was from years of going out to bars
where they got the music cranked way too
[ __ ] loud and you know that [ __ ] were
you hitting on the girl do you live
around here
you're literally leaning into her ear
you're screaming into her [ __ ] ear
like just imagine if there was no music
on and somebody did that to you you'd
punch him in the face but when you're in
those clubs the music is so [ __ ] loud
that someone has to get right near your
ear and yell into it just so you can
hear them so I'm telling you I don't
know how the [ __ ] I got on this subject
I guess you the airbag test you know I
know you're young and you got ear plugs
what are you a [ __ ] queer I'm telling
you put those goddamn things in if you
ever want to experiment one night just
wear one wear one and stand in there for
a [ __ ] half hour and walk out and
take the other one out and feel the
difference you're you're the ear that
didn't have one is gonna feel like it's
underwater and every time you do that
you're doing permanent like you have I
have your ears ring out of nowhere you
just walking down the street and they go
yeah that means you have you have
permanent hearing damage so wear your
earplugs there kids
Jesus Christ that's one of the [ __ ]
corniest things I've ever said but I
don't know it's driven people to suicide
so because it just keeps getting louder
alright here's another here's another
[ __ ] YouTube video this one is
unbelievable
it's called UK's best freerunners and
it's like a six minute video usually I
don't like videos this long but this is
these are these people who basically run
and jump off a like you know out of
second-story windows land and roll and
keep going and do like a [ __ ]
backflip and then run up the side of a
tree and then do another backflip the
[ __ ] unbelievable and the only thing
that this video is missing is I want to
see a free runner get chased by a cop on
foot because this dude one of these guys
he [ __ ] runs at you know those those
big when you go down to like a a wharf
if you're not doing a drug deal or
whatever you know those big containers
that they basically lift off of the ship
and they can put on the back of an
18-wheeler that's what a basically looks
like it looks like that the back of an
18-wheeler this [ __ ] dude is running
full-speed at it and then runs two steps
like bo Jackson up the side of the thing
and then grabs the top of it and does a
pull-up and pulls himself up and this is
all one motion continues to run and then
jumps like a six feet six foot gap over
to this other building where he's got it
the where he's got to reach up jump to
the ledge doesn't
another pull-up and now he's up on the
building all of that takes about a
second and a half and I would just would
have loved to seen a cop chasing this
dude and he just would you know even if
he wanted to shoot him he couldn't have
got the gun out quick enough and it
would just would have been like yeah
pursuits over I don't know he was in
front of me and then he ran up a [ __ ]
building
now dude I'm telling you he ran up a
building I didn't have time to shoot him
well you [ __ ] chase him check that
out here's another quick one lady's
teeth fall out during divorce court
that's pretty much self-explanatory and
then I got a couple of Tourette's videos
there's a guy with Tourette's Tourette's
karaoke Tourette's karaoke and the guys
doing REM losing my religion it's
[ __ ] hilarious then there's uh
there's another one out there called the
best of Tourette's guy and I'm convinced
the guy's an actor because he doesn't
have Tourette's as far as you know being
on the Opie and Anthony show and being
around people with Tourette's for a long
[ __ ] time it's sort of a repetition
of either weird noises and there is
cursing but the way this guy's cursing
it's not tourists it's not Tourette's
Tourette's it's not Tourette's but it's
[ __ ] hilarious so look up Tourette's
guy and that's it that's what I got this
week I'm sorry I have the windows open
we got a heat wave out if you can hear
that [ __ ] lawnmower of the dude down
the street anyways let me know my kite
and this [ __ ] podcast what do we got
here 30 minutes and 16 that's 46 all
right I need another four minutes I
apologize this has been a [ __ ] lame
one this week
what do I got let me height my gigs that
I have coming up oh wait I'm back online
now but now it's back off
Jesus Christ what kind of life am i
living kind of life am i living here I
can't even get on my own goddamn podcast
oh wait wait wait I'm using the schedule
here using my schedule alright this is
what I have coming up this weekend
I am going to be in Albany New York at
the egg at the egg you sons-of-bitches
all you people live in upstate New York
who will like come to Syracuse come to
Albany do the Lake Ontario Playhouse
dude and I always play New York City I
am doing two out-of-the-way gigs in
upstate New York I'm doing the egg
Albany which a lot of people don't
realize is the capital of New York
Albany and then the next night I am at
the the Buffalo what the [ __ ] is this
let me see what we got here
Buffalo Center for the Arts University
at Buffalo Center for the Arts both
shows are at 8 p.m. please come out
please come out and just to show you
what kind of a sports fan I am I'm
hanging out the next day I'm going to
the Bills Jets game and I don't fly out
to the next day and the Buffalo Sabres
are playing the fly is so I'm going to
that game too why the [ __ ] wouldn't you
why wouldn't you and I also have some
cool radio coming up I'm doing Adam
Carolla's podcast on Wednesday October
29th Adam Corolla as far as I know has
the biggest podcast on the Internet the
guy's killing it so I'm gonna be on that
on Wednesday September 29th I'm sorry
September 29th and later on that day I'm
also going to be doing Jamie Foxx's show
on Sirius satellite radio the foxhole
and I believe Jamie's not going to be
there but earthquake and who do I forget
who else is going to be there check that
one out and I'm gonna be on dr. Drew
show Loveline on October 6th and I look
at me moving up in the radio world those
are three famous [ __ ] people shows
I'm doing later on this month I'm coming
out to Minnesota in Chicago to do
one-nighters at theaters and these
tickets are [ __ ] selling tremendously
so if you're thinking of go and get the
tickets now because I am blown away by
the response out there and playing the
Pantages Theater
in Minneapolis Minnesota on October 22nd
I'm playing the victim in Chicago
Illinois the following weekend and and
here's a quick date that I opened I'm
doing one night only at the funny bone
in st. Louis on October 30th October
30th everybody one night only so come on
down check out my new hour all my
material is 100% different from from the
let it go special and speaking of that
let it go will be aired again on Comedy
Central
October 1st please watch it if you can
watch it live because that those are the
only ones that I get credit for as far
as the ratings you guys want to hear a
little behind the behind the curtain
show business [ __ ] this is how it works
how the ratings work is they don't count
TiVo watches if you record it and then
you watch it they don't count it because
you know and I know that you blow
through the commercials and ratings
exists so they can figure out how much
that they can charge advertisers so they
can figure out how many people are
actually watching the goddamn
commercials so October 1st Comedy
Central is showing let it go again and
that's pretty much it
oh and Halloween I'm hanging out I'm
going to the Rams game in st. Louis so
there you go that is it that is it and
just so if you want to plan ahead I got
the funny bone in Columbus Ohio
November 12th 13th and 14th and then I'm
in DC at the Lisner auditorium on
November 19th and then I'm doing
Foxwoods right
Foxwoods there you go Foxwoods on
November 20th there's another one people
don't come to Connecticut I'm in
Connecticut November 20th and then the
last one I will give you was I'm at the
Moore theater in Seattle November 27th
and this is a huge little mini run for
me this is the first time I actually try
to do theaters on my own so I'm really
excited about all this and it's how much
of a sports fan I am I'm flying in the
Friday night to do the radio so you know
do the radio too hyper
the the damn gig and I'm actually gonna
drive down and go to that Trailblazer
hornets game and then I'm going to the
Seattle Seahawks game on the Sunday
afterwards and I brought all of that up
as the lovely Nia just walked in here
the lovely Nia just walked in here does
that make you upset that I spending an
extra day on the road to go to a
football game huh come here come here
come in here come here it's not until
the end of next month I like football I
love you but I like football
come here come over here oh she just
slammed down her purse as if to say you
know you don't like the Rams st. Louis
Rams let me talk about the Rams they're
one of the original teams that made up
the NFL and they were in Los Angeles for
a while and that didn't work out what
worked out for a while and then they
then then they then they move down I
don't care to Anaheim where Disneyland
is one of the happy places and then
after a while come on if I fight this is
a technique you know what I have OCD
alright if I go to that Rams game the
only team in in in in the Midwest first
of all you don't have OCD stop being
dramatic there are people who actually
have OCD and they want to kill
themselves you don't have OCD you like
going to football games see that that's
what you mean your life you need a woman
who can put you in your place when
you're being ridiculous was I being
ridiculous yeah you just gave me the
look really stop cursing on the podcast
you know I had enough of you see that
these supposed to be honest in a [ __ ]
relationship I told you what I'm doing
rather than coming home I'm going to the
[ __ ] Rams game oh I have two weeks
off exactly you should be home I'm gonna
be home during those two weeks these
these [ __ ] games are in like November
except for this fine go I don't want to
see you anyway except for the two
October she just gave me the finger huh
I'm gonna do the pumpkins and I'm also
gonna make the pumpkin bread I'm big on
Halloween everybody I like it you know
what the but you know what to buy any
gifts you know all these kids coming up
the stairs dressed like Godzilla those
yeah it's adorable and I make how great
was the pumpkin Brennan made last year
it was great you make great pumpkin
bread Baker that was all insulting it
was great it was great pumpkin bread
you're a great big you know what you
know I don't you know what I I'm smart
enough not to engage in this with you
this is this is just your way saying
that you love me and you miss me so I'm
not gonna engage in this
I love you too ah see figure that one
out go go pour yourself a bowl of cereal
get out of my face I'm gonna finish this
up Oh [ __ ] cheap shot there's a woman
ever just square up and just go let's go
they don't they wait too you're not
looking and you [ __ ] throw a punch
[ __ ] cheap that was nice that's right
when my appendix used to be did you have
your appendix out yes I did I had it out
back in the day way back in the day on
those little house in the Prairie days
well you almost died of it because
people didn't know what's wrong with you
walking around you face the same color
as glue your dad just going what's wrong
you're being you're being a baby
I feel like this somebody invisible
stabbing me in my side oh come on come
on stop it let's grow up all right
that's the podcast for this week so
please check out check out my special
October first if you missed it and
please buy tickets to my shows I have a
brand new hour I have a big theater tour
coming up and you know what else I
didn't mention I didn't mention this
[ __ ] all right cuz this is how I booked
myself in the road I have to whisper
here so Nia doesn't figure this [ __ ] out
how I booked myself on the road is take
like the funny bone and call
so hi oh alright I'm gonna be there the
12th 13th and 14th of November why did
we pick this weekend you know I mean who
the why the [ __ ] would you ever go to
Columbus Ohio there's only one [ __ ]
reason and that's to go to an Ohio State
Buckeyes game other than that there's no
[ __ ] reason unless you want to join a
militia or maybe use that as your base
camp as you drive down to go see that
chick who plays with the pretenders and
I forget where the [ __ ] she's from so
anyways Ohio State is playing Penn State
that day and I'm really rolling the dice
because of the Flex schedule which is
basically if Ohio State and Penn State
are ranked really high that game will
then become an 8 o'clock game so not
only will I not get to go to the game
nobody will show up to my [ __ ] show
because everyone's gonna be at the
[ __ ] goddamn Ohio State game alright
and I'm telling you people if you if you
if you come from like a town I come from
which is a professional sports team
professional sports town you have no
[ __ ] idea how insane it can get like
as much as they talk about the Yankees
Red Sox rivalry and how [ __ ] and
saying it can't hold a candle to Ohio
State Michigan if you don't believe me
HBO did a documentary on it and it's
it's absolutely [ __ ] insane and I'll
tell you right now if Fenway Park or
Yankee Stadium somehow held a hundred
thousand [ __ ] people they wouldn't
sell it out you couldn't get a hundred
thousand people to go to that I don't
think you get a hundred thousand people
to go to a [ __ ] World Series game but
college football they'll [ __ ] have a
hundred thousand people just to watch
Ohio State kick the [ __ ] out of Bowling
Green they don't give a [ __ ] they just
show up anyways that is the podcast for
this week and I realized that I didn't
address that my podcast has been taken
off of iTunes I believe that was
something that I did I can't figure out
what it is but I have some people
working on it and I didn't even address
it because I'm hoping it's just going to
be a one-week problem and that is it
that's the podcast for this week good
luck to everybody I know who the [ __ ]
Patriots have next week we have the
Dolphins and I'll tell you right now I
don't like that game I don't [ __ ]
like it until we have a goddamn defense
I don't like any game that we're playing
I don't like it but I'm loving Hernandez
I'm loving that guy but I'm hoping Moss
is gonna get some more touches because
he's gonna start bitching or something I
don't [ __ ] know god damn it that's my
prediction right now the way we've
played the first three weeks and all the
points we let up I'm saying we're gonna
go nine and seven and we might even be
tied for second with the Dolphins and
they might even be ten and six Jets
might go eleven and five I got away to
the Jets actually play another contender
I know we're playing the Steelers I
don't know if the Jets play them but
that's that's gonna be a big game when
Ben Roethlisberger is back I'll tell you
what jet fans I'll tell you this right
now okay and know that the reason why I
gave the Jets so much [ __ ] a is because
they're from New York and also because
they were talking so much [ __ ] [ __ ]
that's what happens that's what happens
and noticed after they got their [ __ ]
asses kicked nating at their asses
kicked but they lost where's all the
[ __ ] talking now they shut the [ __ ] up
which is actually me hating the Jets I
kind of wish that they beat the Ravens
because they still would have been
talking and then they would have been in
a situation like the 2007 Patriots where
the entire league wants to kick the [ __ ]
out of you and eventually someone does
and you go home sad with your head
hanging down but I will tell you this if
you guys do play the [ __ ] Steelers
all right and Big Ben is back and you
know and you guys beat him then I will
say you guys are for real all right and
as much as you New Yorkers can't [ __ ]
stand stand me you got to admit that's
how you have to be you can't just say
you're the [ __ ] and not be the [ __ ] and
then everybody just says you're the [ __ ]
unless you're Peyton Manning of course
who can just do no [ __ ] wrong right
right once again he's off to a tease on
a [ __ ] tear putting up ridiculous
numbers and I'll tell you this [ __ ]
cult fans if Peyton Manning wins three
Super Bowls with the regular season
stats that he's put up if you want to
say
that he's the best guy who ever played
that position at that point I would have
a hard time argument because he would he
would have that final piece that he
needed which was leading your team in
the playoffs to the promised land
as opposed to getting him to the
promised land you're right there at the
gates of Walley world and then throwing
a pick six to [ __ ] John Candy and he
runs it back 60 yards alright so for all
you [ __ ] guys because you guys love
you team so much you're not even
listening to what I'm saying all I said
was Rex Ryan is is out of his [ __ ]
mind he's not as confident as he acts he
cries himself to sleep with a [ __ ]
gallon of ice cream every night and he
has a as a chronic need to be liked and
I am right on all of those [ __ ]
points I don't give a [ __ ]
and also said that all this [ __ ] you
were talking was [ __ ] which was
proven in the first [ __ ] week when
you lost alright so when you when you
beat a legitimate Super Bowl contender
which you have yet to [ __ ] play all
you've played so far is one team that
has a playoff level defense and you
didn't beat them all right really do you
think that dolphins are gonna win the
Super Bowl do you really think you're
gonna run into them again in the [ __ ]
playoffs with their no-name QB you're
not do you think the Patriots are gonna
do anything letting up 30 points a
[ __ ] game they're not I know that
because Belichick is still there and Tom
Brady's still there you think that
there's still the O 4 or o 7 Pats
they're not they're not this is this is
a whole new [ __ ] team and and I mean
it's [ __ ] ridiculous we have to score
like 35 38 points to get a victory
we scored 38 points on the bills 38
points and it was still a nail-biter
right down to the [ __ ] end alright
whatever
it's [ __ ] frustrating and you guys
couldn't beat the Dolphins until the
last goddamn play of the game and you
guys are sitting there talking Superbowl
is that what you I scream [ __ ] eating
[ __ ] down there in New York is that what
you're doing whose team actually plays
in New Jersey all you douche bags go
words are called in New England Patriots
there's not even a Boston team that's
how dumb New Yorkers are they don't
realize that Massachusetts is in New
England it's a region of the Northeast
all right for all
you [ __ ] who don't know your history
the Boston Patriots started out they
played at Nickerson Field nobody showed
up because nobody knew who the [ __ ] they
were it was considered an inferior
league they were going bankrupt and in a
desperate attempt to try to rope in more
[ __ ] fans they switched to New
England Patriots something that I have
never liked I still think that they
should be called the Boston Patriots all
that [ __ ] Patriot Tea Party horseshit
all happened in Boston they should be
called the Boston Patriots but they're
not so that's why but Boston is in New
England you dumb New Yorker [ __ ] and
you guys got a lot of nerve considering
the New York Jets and the New York
Giants play in New Jersey and share a
[ __ ] stadium so why don't you guys
stand the [ __ ] down all right see that's
what always happens I always make good
points about football and then my hatred
of New York just comes up but a minute
you love it you love it every god do you
know something I actually don't even
hate the Giants I actually like the
Giants I don't know I like the uniforms
I like the old helmet that they went
back to I like them I like their style
of play that's Smash Mouth defensive
[ __ ] I know that they kind of sucked so
far but uh Coughlin is a good coach
maybe you can turn it around I don't I
don't know what but uh there's something
about the Jets
I just they're you know what it is their
fans are desperate and there's just
something when you smell desperation you
just want to see failure you know
there's just something about that silly
little fireman on top of his boyfriend's
shoulders and their 1920s cheer Jay ETS
Jets and they and they think that that
cheer is awesome that's what kills me
the same way it kills me when Red Sox
fans sing Sweet Caroline and they think
it's awesome to be going ba bum bum with
your [ __ ] chicks head on your
shoulder I swear to God if I could if I
became the next Hitler we're going big
on this one the people that I would
target would be Red Sox fans anybody who
sings pop-up I'm in the seventh inning
of a Red Sox game
and anyone who puts a fireman on their
shoulder and goes J ETS Jets Jets Jets
that's it you're out you're [ __ ] out
you're done all right
you're not part of my master plan oh
geez how [ __ ] up was that well go [ __ ]
yourself that's the podcast for this
week god bless all you please come out
to my shows I got a brand new hour and
III think I have a new girl I think I
have a new fun joke about a goat I'm
hoping it killed in Nashville but God
knows those peat God knows the people
down there come on man who's kidding who
how does it go joke not kill in [ __ ]
Tennessee all right the real test it's
not even gonna be in Albany I think
he'll be in Buffalo Albany I don't know
there's a lot of farmland around there
do you know that's the highway I hate
the most the 87 north just because for
so much of my career I drove up there in
either a bus or a rental car just going
to some [ __ ] nightmare of a gig so I
just always associated with that I have
talked too long I have overstayed my
welcome
god bless all yeah I'll see you next
week
[Music]
you